the brain's cognitive functions include
memory which is the process of
information retention and retrieval
memories form in the hippocampus
which consists of information processing
cells called neurons
each neuron receives chemical messages
from other neurons via dendrites
then converts the message to an
electrical charge called an action
potential
in the space between them
neurons release stimulatory chemicals
called neurotransmitters
which bind with receptors on the
receiving cell
and transfer information
Alzheimer's disease is a gradual
degenerative brain condition in which
neurons in the memory and other
cognitive areas of the brain lose
function and die
resulting in Progressive memory loss
first then difficulties learning and
communicating
and eventually failing basic functions
like breathing
in healthy neurons
enzymes help process a protein called
amyloid precursor protein into fragments
which help with normal cell function
in Alzheimer's abnormal enzymatic
processing
produces fragments that include a sticky
peptide called beta amyloid
beta amyloid accumulates in the
extracellular space
forming clumps called amyloid plaques
these clumps block the electrical and
chemical connections between neurons
inside healthy neurons
microtubules and Tau proteins form an
orderly structure
that carries ions and nutrients within
the cell in Alzheimer's chemical changes
inside the neurons damaged Tau
twisting microtubules abnormally into
neurofibrillary tangles
which disrupts ion and nutrient delivery
within the cell
as the plaques and Tangles multiply
throughout brain tissue
neural connections diminish and the
malnourished cells lose function
resulting in widespread neural death
reduced brain mass
and severe cognitive and functional
impairment
there is no cure for Alzheimer's but
current treatments include
cholinesterase inhibitors
which delayed the breakdown of
acetylcholine a neurotransmitter
important for memory and learning
and anti-glutomatergic medications which
regulate the activity of glutamate
another neurotransmitter essential for
memory and learning
by blocking excessive glutamate binding
to neurons thus preventing neuronal
dysfunction and death